وعلى عكس الهدوء النسبيه الذي سبق مباراه
ايران والولايات المتحده في مونديال
1998 بفرنسا لا يبدو ان الوضع في مونديال
2022 سيسمحوا بصوره تذكاريه اخرى قبل 24
عاما كانت خطابات الاصلاحيه محمد خاتمي
وبي كلينتون تروجوا للسلام لكن اليوم
الدولتان وفي المونديال الذي ينطلق غدا
ستتواجهاني رياضيا مباراه ستشهد التحامات
ابداعيه بالطبع لكن هذه الالتحامات لن
تنتهي بنهايه التسعين دقيقه بل ستستمر
سياسيا
الصراعوا يتاجل على جبهات عده الاتفاق
النووي الذي يموت سرديا كما ذكرنا وجبه
هذا التظاهرات التي تعوم الشوارع طهران
والاخيره تلتهم واشنطن ميرارا بتغذيتها
واشعالها والنزاع السياسيه داخل منتخب
ايران بيحددته المدير البرتغالي
كارلوس كروش استدعى احدا نجومه سردار
ازمون فما القصه
سلطاته الطيران حاولت الضغط الاستبعاده
لماذا دعم الاحتجاجات الشعبيه هذه ليست
المره الاولى التي يثير فيها لاعبو منتخب
ايران غضبا النظام مع انطلاق مظاهرات
الحركه الخضراء ايضا في عام 2009 دخل عدد
من نجوم المنتخب الايراني بشارات خضراء في
استاد العاصمه الكوريه الجنوبيه صول قبل
ان يختفي بين الشوطين واجبر على نزع الذهب
بالطبع سويسرا وصربيا مباراه سياسيه اخرى
منتظره جرانيت تشاكا وشيردان شاكيري اثنان
من بين 200,000 سويسري من اصلبيه اثار
الثنائي مشاعره متناقضه خلال المونديال
الماضي فرحه في كسوفو وغضب في صربيا بعد
الاحتفال بهدفيهما بتقليده شعار النسر
بالراسين الذي يرمز الى ما يطلق عليها
البانيا الكبرى وقبل ذلك باربع سنوات لعام
2014 في بلغراد توقفت مباراه اخرى بين
البلدين على ما يمثل البانيا الكبرى القي
في الملعب ولاعب صربي امسك بالعلم ما ادى
الى رد فعل غاضب من اللاعبين الالبان
الذين حاولوا انتزاعه منه لتبدا المشاجره
وبالتالي اجتياح الجماهير للملعب